τικκάθοδο θερωρίσει ότι αυτό βοήθισε την αγορα να κοινηθεί ή ακόμη έχουμε βήματα ναγίνουν έχουμε
βήματα να γίνούν μην ξεχνάμε ότι είχαμε μάθημε μιδενικά επιτόκια ξαυτικά πήγαμε στο δέσςατες ρακο
ντε τεράστη αλαγή μπήκαν λεφτά από δημόσια ταμί από ξευρωπαϊκό επίπεδο για να δώσουν όθησης
την οικονομία τώρα έπεσε σε σημαντικά τώρα δευτυσημαντικά με στόχο να πάμε στο δύο τις
εκατόμεχριο έλος του χρόνο αυτό αυτή είναι η μεγάληκόνα και να σταθερροποιηθεί κάπό εκεί άρα
να να να παίσει σημαντικά από το δέτερας το δύο εντός ένα με ανάμηση χρόνοαπό
την άλλη όμως και λόγο πληθορισμού το κόστος γεννικότερα έχει αυξηθεί στησε όλος τους τομίς
και ι δικότερα στην κύπρο έ ένας από τους μεγάλους τομίς είν τοτο μέαστον να
κινήτο και οτομέα στω νακινήδω ν έχει αυξηθεί το κόστος και έλογο των επιτοκίων γιατί
το χρήμα ήταν επολύ πιο ακριβών αλλά και βεβαίως λόγο τς ξεενης ζήτησες ναι θέλουμε
να έρχονται ξένι ναμένος στην κύπρο αλλά δυστυχώς χριδμιουργείται μια δεύτερη ταχίτητα ατομν που είναι
η κύπριπολίτες με μές με μεσέατάξει μει σοδήματα που δεν του σε ακόμα και μεδανισμό
δεν μπορούν να δα βγάλουν πέρα άρα όλα αυτό το μίγμα σύντο γεονός ότι το
πλαίσιο να νιοδότησης έχει γίνει πολύ πιο απαιτητικό και αυστρο ητράδε τράπεζες έχουν χρήμα σήμερα
και θέλουν να το δώσενες εδώ και πάρα πολλά χρόνια λά ιστο για πέντε εξι
χρόνια που έχουν ορθοποδήσει τα μεγαλήνως κατριους πρόκληση είναι να βρούν διώσιμους ταν ιολίπτας θέλουν
να να να ρίξου χρήα στην αγορα αλλά είται λόγοκο τις εποπθείας της ευρωπακής καιντρικής
τράβεζας και το αυστηρού θεσμικού πλαισίου δεν βρίσκουν αρκεδούς που μπορούν να να τηρήσουν τα
ή το γεγονός ότι πολύτομείς της αγοράς είναι κορεσμένει εγώ λέω πάντα δος